what's going on there citizens of the
reject Nation we are back to continue
the bad batch episode three today I'm
here with my buddy we got a really great
response last time you earned your spot
back here at the recheck Nation Michaels
my Star Wars nerdy friend Michael tesler
who by the way I forgot to mention this
last time he actually has a really up
and coming
some might say it's already come and
become successful I don't care right
it's called multi-house you guys should
go check it out you got an Instagram
page yeah we sure do yeah website at
multi house I O plug it and that's our
website and that's also our Instagram
handle good stuff so yeah we do all
different sorts of uh going over some
multi-platform storytelling I know how
to sell the sizzle come on everything is
inspired by Star Wars
leave a like people leave a like that
would be very much appreciated helps
this video out as always full and
stretch and watch long story stick with
your own copy of the bad match available
for super sexy Rejects at our patreon
page come over there to see what else we
check out exclusively reaction Hots and
Watch Dogs included Michael Tesla are
you ready oh you know what last Sunday
I prayed at the altar of Dave filoni you
know this to be a great episode and it's
gonna be the best I'm so excited episode
three let's go
what's this episode called oh I'm ready
clone Cody Cody
he's in the trailers
where are we
I love Interstellar such a good movie
yeah look at all that corn
one Final Approach governor
homeboy looks tense
I'm really enjoying the mood of this
episode already yeah right
I love their armor I am here to relieve
you of your title mistress Ames by order
of the Galactic Empire as I have told
your government Essex does not fall
under Imperial jurisdiction
take your forces and leave your request
has been received reviewed and as you
can see rejected how disappointing
oh
ran around here Roger Roger
I have a message for your Empire
what was the message
[Laughter]
[Music]
that bed does not look comfortable no
foreign
I heard the defense recruitment bill is
up for a vote again let's hope it
doesn't pass for our sake
oh
he's a real reject
oh foreign
[Music]
immediately
it's so solemn now I know
what are my orders the Imperial Governor
has been taken hostage by insurgents
demanding desex be recognized as an
independent Planet fools what Squad will
I be leading you're not ready to play
Commander again your new Commander will
brief you on the details
Cody
those might be some aggressive
negotiations I love this like Vietnam
memorial wall of
foreign
it's been a while good to see you
Commander Cody
the paint job when I heard you were
cleared for Duty I requested you
specifically the rest of Clone Force 99
went rogue after Order 66 came through
surprised
rumors are more and more clones a pin
questioning the order
clone Rebellion like the Jedi
[Music]
good soldiers follow orders
God those words are haunting seize the
city and taken Governor Groton hostage
the insurgents are expecting a
diplomatic Envoy catch them by surprise
Wipe Out the droids and locate Governor
Groton sounds easy enough
I love seeing Cody back Imperial shuttle
995 requesting permission to enter desk
access base
granted you are cleared for approach
I love this planet it is gorgeous he
knew the Republic was corrupt that it
would collapse and become something
worse a Galactic Empire you will lose
this as well it's an attractive ass
leader right there
let's welcome them shall we it looks
like they've chosen not to negotiate
this guy seems so cowardly how did he
get to this position
that's a great question
there's a lot of planets a lot of job
opportunities
move into position
it's probably tarkin's nephew
it's a nepotism rule
space nepotism
oh boy
God I've missed the droids
the Imperial vessel has been neutralized
and crashed in sector five send Scouts
to the wreck check for any survivors yes
Governor this reminds me of like the
2004 Clone Wars like early animation
when they crash in the city
that doesn't look good yeah for them we
found the shuttle there are no survivors
barely scoped it out man
is it just trust those two
Notch we'll have to
oh there's a bunch of them the squad's
two engine to continue crosshairs
trust me
you do make things interesting
this is cool this feels like a classic
Clone Wars episode but they're the
Clones are bad it's interesting
whatever clever aim at certain spots
that they're off at same
right into the eye
God I forgot how badass he is he was
literally in a Crosshair
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
Professor got more shots in a row than
any Stormtrooper in all of A New Hope
yeah
[Music]
thank you
I've always loved when they fought the
droids because you can get away with
more violence oh so much violence Nova
you're with us we'll take the north axis
team two take this out don't split their
assault recommend protocol four see it
done I'll secure grunt man I would have
planted like Claymore mines everywhere
a lot of running
[Music]
good call okay
it's okay we're here to help
[Laughter]
[Music]
him
yes I love them
[Music]
[Applause]
ah nice nice nice
[Music]
the plane this is a really cool episode
yeah so far so good
[Music]
[Applause]
damn they're just messing [ __ ] up
[Applause]
so I can't get a clear line of sight
let's remedies
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
oh man
oh [ __ ] heesh
secure the tower
[Music]
oh [ __ ] ah yeah
[Music]
dude I mean
they're not on the right side but I have
Rudy for them
[Music]
they're learning
oh no oh
vibroblood right there he used a knife
I'll take out the tech Droid I can make
the shot from here give me a line of
sight I'm worried about Cody
everybody's just gonna kill them off
I think they have to right right now
well not right now but
[Music]
oh
awesome
that was great
oh [ __ ]
nice shot
worried about Cody
cross her gonna do it we are an
independent system we're not here to
debate politics with you your droid army
have attacked two Imperial convoys we
were defending ourselves
[Laughter]
we are not the enemy the Empire seeks to
establish peace and Order throughout the
Galaxy you believe that Cody there was a
time I believed in that
so much so my colleague Mina bonteri and
I put forth a treaty with secretary
that's reference your Supreme Chancellor
rejected it I realized then
peace was never an option
uh-oh it might be a Crosshair it's an
option now we both live through one war
let's not start another
too many people have died already
mainly droids
do this for your people
wow Cody now execute her sir I promised
a peaceful you did I didn't now execute
her you [ __ ]
I gave you an order follow it or face
the consequences for discipline
[Applause]
cold-hearted guy yeah
oh that tune
put a body in the Square let it be a
warning to the rest of them are you
sniveling snake
something tells me Cody's gonna have a
character r
ude
I love that I think we might really get
a clone Rebellion
[Music]
I know but what's Rector up to
I don't know
I kind of wish this was the first
episode yeah right
this is what I've been waiting for
foreign
gets to reunite with Rex yeah I hope so
so fun and interesting watching the
Clones just slowly become more and more
relevant we're soldiers we do what needs
to be done
you know it makes us different from
battle droids Choice our own choices
we have to live with him too
[Music]
it's cool how when they first met they
were on different sides and yeah this
last conversation slipped even he looks
in Conflict too yeah
he's gonna attack text Hunter yeah hey
Rob
after your success on desex I'm
entrusting you with another mission
report to cc1226
why not Commander Cody
cc2224 it appears he has gone a war
what loyalty does not seem to be as
advertised anymore no way are these
clones around you keep disappearing
no sir then you're dismissed
crosshairs like I'm just trying to be a
good soldier yeah I'm getting blamed for
everyone [ __ ] I guess he is the solitary
clone
[Music]
[Music]
that was great what great that was a
great episode great great content man
that was good content I for my Star Wars
brain yeah I love love love watching
this like descent
of the Clones and like being forced to
come to terms with the reality of their
actions uh with Order 66 and like you
know I I they're definitely setting
something up major uh which I'm just I'm
so jazzed about it I know that was
awesome I like that way more than the
first two episodes
I just love the I love the Sinister tone
and how the conflict seems to just have
a a switcher room because when's the
last time we saw Cody was was it like in
terms of timeline for us was it episode
three it was episode three I mean he he
had just shot Kenobi down uh and and
then he was on the hunt for him and and
that was that for Cody uh which like you
know in in Clone Wars they built that
relationship up so much which just made
the payoff in episode three like all the
more devastating you know I can't even
imagine
in in the same way that that you know
Ahsoka directs I feel like you know
Obi-Wan was the Cody yeah um and it
really like it's it's nice to see them
going AWOL I just how do you think the
chips are gonna feed into everything
like and like the consequences of I
guess how much control do you think the
Empire still has over the Clones it
looks like it's
looks like the battery life on the chips
are
he's a recharge it seems like to me but
just the philosophical discussions and
just how nuanced and
ridiculously complex it is to pair up
both Crosshair who we saw at the end of
last season who is in a constant like
are you gonna be good or not you know
yeah yeah but we're always wondering
that with him especially for the fact
that he let them live in at the end of
uh the first season
who's obviously still in some type of
conflict over the whole thing it seems
like more often than not he's gonna just
follow orders and do the executions do
what he needs to be done but to pair him
up with Cody based off I mean going off
like everything that you were just
saying yeah about Cody but having like
these little reminders because it's been
a while since we've seen Cody but
there's this like gap of History here
with Cody that we haven't seen from
Order 66 to now where it seems like
there has been a toll that's been taken
on him and that's the moment in time
we're meeting up with him because when
he says that line about like their
Traders like the Jedi you could just see
that that trauma yeah the pain like did
I make the right choice yeah and is it
even really a choice you know and I
think even being cognitively aware you
know I mean even as like the rumors
among the Clones of the existence of the
chips because that's the other question
does Cody even know that he has a Jeb
um I don't think he does most people
most of them didn't know and I but I
feel like that that creates such an
interesting kind of you know as they
talk about like the Clone Rebellion uh
that's kind of I think is what we're
actually building up to this season
um it would certainly explain what
happened to all the Clones uh because
I'm tripping me you put a gold damn chip
in me reckon uh no but you're you're
absolutely right
um uh yeah I'm just like
it's it's brilliant watching the Clones
be stripped of their individuality like
they started the episode showing Cody
instead of his signature yellow which
like I still have my Cody action figure
back home like uh to to put him into
this like gray and to take it away where
Crosser didn't even recognize him at
first and then at the tail end of the
episode Crosshair uses his actual name
Cody instead of his you know his his CC
uh signature uh and the fact that the
imperial you know the vice admiral
didn't even like acknowledge that or uh
just it kind of goes to show that you
know the the Empire is um
it doesn't want to run the risk of
individual thought because individual
thought and any kind of you know
utilitarian Society is risky and
dangerous uh I agree you know so
oh yeah definitely I feel like our
country should be more that way no idea
listen it's got to stop letting people
make choices
I feel like if we had more you know like
what they do in like North Korea
where you get eight haircuts
simple it's working out for the Clones
every day Steve Jobs wore the same shirt
yeah that's all I'm saying it's it's
decision fatigue uh no it's it's also
it's also cool I appreciate that they're
using different helmet and armor it's
what it's called Uh I appreciate that
they're they're using different armor
types to distinguish and kind of give us
a visual sense of things are shifting in
terms of look at these non-clone uh
Storm Troopers
um so yeah yeah good point it's a good
point uh and it was really really kind
of omnipresent this episode whereas in
the first two episodes I don't think we
saw any just yet and I bet as the season
progresses clones are gonna start
mysteriously kind of fading out well I
what I really really appreciate about
this particular episode was it felt like
a classic Clone Wars episode
but the ironic sense that you're not
watching the Clones fight on the right
side and I thought that was fascinating
because you're like kind of with them
they're like they're like kicking ass
and shooting droids and [ __ ] but if they
were like people yeah it would be so
messed up but that's that's the trick
they were playing on us though yeah and
they got both of us yeah because they're
like cool cool
they're fighting for the Empire yeah
yeah and and I think that's the
Brilliance of the Poetry of of this
episode it Rhymes it does it does George
Lucas knew what he was talking about
from the beginning it's all connected Dr
Seuss uh no it's uh yeah uh all the
Clones down in cloneville
uh not it's so great to
you know I thought like the final season
of Clone Wars minus like the first two
or three episodes were like just some of
the best animated content I've ever seen
in my entire life and the final episodes
were
like some of the best Star Wars yeah
yeah I mean it and it it holds up uh
because I re-watch it every night
I wish I was kidding uh but this this
was great because it does feel like that
continuation
um whereas when we follow the rest of
the bad batch the tone and and the feel
feels a bit more like Rebels
um where it's a bit lighter it's a bit
it's a bit more fun that's kind of the
point though of this show isn't it it's
a bit of a it's a connective thread
between Clone Wars the rebels yeah which
which is beautiful
um and and I still prefer this yeah I
mean but dark Booty Star Wars is the
best yeah yeah
are you on antidepressants you'll
probably you'll probably like this side
of things uh no it's it's definitely
it's really interesting watching
them try to navigate that in a way that
that makes sense
um and I really I feel like a clone
Rebellion is the perfect way like how do
we get all these players back in the
same place at the same time yeah um
they're reused uh and the Clone
Rebellion you know or I guess you know
what's the difference between a
rebellion or a revolution you know
rebellions fail uh uh so it'll be
interesting to kind of watch
I mean they all have to die right like I
mean that's how this
you know when in Rebels we really only
pick up with with Rex Gregor wolf and
Gregor
um you know where's Cody where's the
rest of the the band you know so it
cloneville
I wanna we should write that
uh I got a sliding pool
how the clankers Stole Christmas you
walk in you're like which one's which
can't tell them apart
are you clone racist Greg a little bit a
little bit yeah I almost got excited at
Cody when uh you know the when across
here what's up in the cafeteria but like
I'm not sure if that's code
is that Cody
nah you're just a racist
I don't care what you're saying it's
it's definitely nice to know that clone
lunch time is just like Middle School
like God these guys that they fought
wars together they've been through all
this stuff and they won't even like
they're still gonna bully the little
little bad batch but oh yeah that was a
great episode I loved it I I love that
one that made me really happy Yeah I'm
I'm I'm curious you know for for the you
know the reject Nation what do you guys
think is how are they going to bring all
these characters back into the same
place because that's what I'm trying to
are you trying to trade engagement with
the audience I well I I they were so
nice to me they they said nice things
it's a whole thing where you ask the
audience a question of something to
respond to in the comments yeah well
it's it's just you know I I don't
remember who said it but somebody in the
comments brought up the Clone rebellion
and I when I first read it I was like
nah they're not gonna do that this
season and uh well you were right I
think
um I think I think this time gets like
season seven a bad batch
I want I want to follow the bad batch at
their like really nice retirement home
on Alderaan yeah and they're like man
we finally did it finally finally
settling down and then I want the Death
Star to shoot down and I want it to end
with
I want them all to make it but just uh
you know they died like a car crash or
something yeah something like like what
you wouldn't like I I want to see like
like Wrecker
or Tech I want to see Tech OD on death
sticks
[Laughter]
thanks guys for being here leave a like
follow Michael president CEO dictator of
multi-house
individuality is a recipe for disaster
that's where mission statement is
uh reject Nation May the force be with
you thanks for having me as always we've
got to end this with a patron of the day
shout out oh uh well we have a
Andrew Hayes Andrew you've been a patron
of ours for many years now I know a long
time six years is going on I was gonna
say you were in diapers back then like
no I was a child and now I'm thinking
that it would be great if I could clone
more people like you if I could just
clone an Andrew Hayes and if I could
just have a patreon page full of nothing
but Andrew Hayes's you haven't met
Andrew I love Andrew he's a short like
stocky guy like from New Jersey hey no
I'm from Long Island
he's and imagine just a bunch of them
and what's great about Andrew is I
haven't heard from him in like a year
yeah I think his card is just on file
and he completely forgot to remember God
uh Andrew Endor uh his bank uh if you
have a complaint
he's also one of our highest punishments
I'm convinced he's just left it out of
his credit card
I've heard from this guy in so long and
he's just here he still does it and I
love him so much what a sweet guy what
if what if he died
um what what if what if just nobody
knows how to turn it off ignorance is
bliss is what I say
well Andrew uh you're a real MVP you're
a really is man includes his reputation
to keep your car on file whatever for
however long you're great thank you for
the love Andrew uh Greg really
appreciates it
I do I thought there's more to that
sentence uh yeah I do appreciate it
buddy and you are an amazing soul and I
hope I hope I hear from you properly
soon happy New Year bud happy New Year
[Music]